Michel recard vous avez 38 ans vous
n'êtes pas un homme de la 4e République
pas d'avantage un homme de la 5e vous
n'êtes ni député
ni sénateur vous nêtes pas donc ce que
l'on appelle couramment et peut-être des
fois péjorativement un politicien
cependant vous êtes en revanche
secrétaire national du Parti socialiste
unifié et candidat pour le socialisme
c'est bien ça tout à fait disons plus
simplement que je ne suis pas un notable
mais que je suis tout de même un
militant politique un homme politique
bien vous nêtes pas un homme du passé
vous entrez de plein pied dans le
présent dans l'actualité est-ce que vous
pensez que vous êtes un homme
d'avenir
euh on verra bien comment voulez-vous
que je le
sache ce que je crois plus important de
dire c'est que j'ai l'impression de me
battre pour pour une force et pour un
projet d'avenir euh les hommes ça peut
changer l'important c'est l'objet de
leur bataille c'est avec qui ils se
battent et effectivement aujourd'hui
menant cette bataille au nom de de tout
un courant d'hommees organisés sur le
plan politique ou syndical j'ai
l'impression que nous avons l'avenir
avec nous et devant nous cependant si
l'on en croit les sondages vous n'avez
apparemment pas beaucoup de chance
d'être élu président de la République le
1er juin ni même le 15 juin alors quel
est le sens de cette candidature et bien
d'abord sondage pour sondage on a
commencé à faire avant que les vraies
questions n été posées à l'opinion
souvenez-vous de 1965 les résultats
finaux étaient très différents des
sondages du début on commence à peine à
discuter dans cette campagne les vraies
questions tout ce qui a été enregistré
paravant c'était sur des notoriétés
établi c'était sur la connaissance qu'on
avait de Monsieur Intel ou de Monsieur
Intel je ne crois pas que ce soit très
important je suis persuadé moi que
l'opinion toute entière les Françaises
et les Français commencent maintenant à
réfléchir attentivement à la avenir que
l'on propose à ce pays et c'est ça qui
va être en jeu le sens de ma candidature
mais c'est tout simplement de proposer
un avenir socialiste de définir de faire
comprendre le projet socialiste de
décrire comment c'est un projet pour
aujourd'hui pour tout de suite et et se
faisant de travailler déjà à
reconstruire la gauche autour de ce
projet et bien avant de parler
précisément de ce projet socialiste et
de l'ambition que que vous avez je
voudrais quand même vous poser encore
une question sur sur le plan personnel
vous êtes technicien de l'Économie des
Finances vous êtes on le sait inspecteur
des finances et on dit volontiers de
vous que vous êtes un technocrate alors
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
définition si j'étais un technocrate je
ne serais pas
là j'aurais certainement continué à
faire ce qu'on appelle une grande
carrière et c'était
possible ce
métier dont on parle temps ce métier il
m'a permis de
découvrir la machine compliquée de
l'État comme elle est de découvrir
l'injustice fiscale chez les inspecteurs
des impôts de découvrir comment marche
ou ne marche pas tel ou tel aspect de
ces bureaux de cette machine compliquée
de découvrir surtout qui décide pour
nous et au nom de quels intérêts alors
ayant découvert ça il m'a semblé plus
urgent justement de le combattre et
c'est donc pourquoi je suis le contraire
d'un technocrate demandez donc à mes
anciens collègues bien alors vous avez
dit et vous le dites et vous le répéter
que le socialisme est un combat vous
parlez de lutte vous parlez de de
difficultés à établir le socialisme
alors ma question est la suivante est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que en parlant de
combat il faut identifier les ennemis
parce que s'il y a combat il y a ennemis
alors ces ennemis qui sont-ils comment
se manifestent-t-ils ou sont-ils ça
c'est assez
simple prenez le cas d'un jeune ménage
qui veut se
loger trouve pas à se loger c'est trop
cher et quand il commence à courir les
agences à visiter des appartements puis
à s'entend de poser des conditions il
comprend assez vite comment ça se passe
et il découvre le mécanisme de la
spéculation prenez le cas des paysans
qui s'aperçoivent et qui apprennent
petit à petit que leurs produits sont
vendus à Paris entre 3 5 et 6 fois plus
chers que ce qu'on les leur paye à eux
et bien sûr il y aura des frais de
transport il y aura don des frais
annexes mais ils savent bien que quelque
chose se passe quelque part et cet
ennemi- là c'est c'est le parasite c'est
l'intermédiaire c'est surtout la
spéculation regardez aussi euh ce qui se
passe sur le plan monétaire euh notre
monnaie est soumise à des assauts
incroyables et tout ça c'est le jeu
d'une spéculation c'est tout ça
l'ennemi de manière plus précise c'est
l'ensemble des forces et surtout
l'ensemble des hommes des groupes qui
parce qu'il dispose de grands capitaux
décide de ce qui concerne chacun de nous
sans nous consulter c'est ce système qui
permet au patronat de décider l'embauche
comme le licenciement comme la paye ou
l'absence d'augmentation de la paye sans
consulter personne en fonction de ses
seuls intérêts tout ça ça porte un nom
c'est le capitalisme et l'ennemi c'est
ça alors dans ce combat vous avez
identifié l'ennemi mais il vous faut
aussi des des atouts des alliés alors
qui
sont-ils alors ceuxl sont innombrables
c'est
profondément tous les Français toutes
les Françaises tous les travailleurs
aussi parce que l'essentiel se passe sur
les lieux de la production sur le plan
de la production tous ceux qui ont
intérêt à ce que ça
change le difficile c'est qu'il se
rendent compte et qu'ils déterminent
eux-mêmes l'ennemi là où il est mais
mais une fois cela clairement établi
tous ceux qui ont intérêt à une société
plus juste à une société plus libre à
une société où on ne soit pas soumis aux
décisions des autres mais où on contrôle
son propre destin tout cela ils ont
intérêt à la victoire du socialisme et
petit à petit vont se mettre à mener ce
même combat alors dans ce combat quelle
place faites-vous au syndicat bah
justement essentiel parce que ce sont
les grandes organisations qui
représentent justement tous ces
travailleurs tous les travailleurs c'est
eux qui font peser
les c'est eux qui posent les premiers
problèmes et qui mènent les premières
luttes contre les décisions injustes que
nous subissons et notamment dans
l'entreprise c'est par le mouvement
syndical que doit passer cette bataille
seulement il faut qu'il se détermine
librement qu'il choisisse lui-même ses
objectifs les politiques n'ont pas de
leçons à lui donner ils ont comme métier
de traduire au niveau de la politique et
au niveau de l'État les objectifs les
besoins des travailleurs mais pas plus
ça commence au niveau de l'entreprise et
par la lutte des organisations
syndicales oui cela veut dire que vous
êtes pour l'autonomie des syndicats par
rapport aux partis politiques absolument
nous l'avons dit à de nombreuses
reprises nous avons eu une grande
discussion là-dessus mais
finalement le choix était parfaitement
net nous avons rejeté toute idée de de
courroie de transmission de commandement
bureaucratique et ça va même plus loin
dans l'idée pour l'avenir alors que nous
avons dans une société socialiste le
mouvement syndical ne doit pas gérer les
entreprises il doit rester libre de
critiquer cette gestion et par
conséquent les conseils de travailleurs
seront élus distinctement du mouvement
syndical monsieur rard lorsque vous
parlez du socialisme vous en parlez avec
ferveur avec chaleur vous en parlez en
terme de combat vous parlez aussi
volontiers du mois de mai vous l'avez
fait dans votre première intervention à
la télévision vous en parlez aussi comme
d'un mouvement porteur d'espérance un
grand moment d'espoir et beaucoup de
candidats à la présidence de la
République au contraire rejettent l'idée
du mois de mai et n'en retiennent que
l'aspect des désordres qui se sont créés
et menace même au cas où il ne serait
pas élu que de tels désordres se
reproduisent vous vous adoptez une
politique tout à fait différente une
attitude différente alors est-ce que
vous ne croyez pas que en parlant dans
ces termes du socialisme et du mois de
mai vous n'allez pas à contrecourant de
l'opinion publique et que vous n'allez
pas ainsi accréditer la thèse qui qui
est connue quand même du socialisme qui
fait
peur je ne crois pas parce
qu'enfin qui a eu peur en mai sinon ceux
qui n'avaient pas intérêt à ce que les
choses
change
qu'ensuite
la la télévision tel qu'on la connaî là
une bonne partie de nos moyens de presse
écrites est organisé cette crainte
cette crainte de ceux qui ont des
privilèges cette crainte de ceux qui en
ma ont senti vaciller leur pouvoir
qu'ensuite elle se soit
exprimé par les moyens de ceux qui
commandent notre système d'information
quoi de plus logique souvenons-nous
mieux du mois de mai et parlons-en en
détail qu'est-ce qui s'est passé cette
grève cette formidable grève 9 à 10
millions de travailleurs a été
totalement Pacifique totalement
Pacifique sauf en deux endroits àin et à
Soo quand on a fait donner la police à
ce moment-là on a vu que la classe
ouvrière se défendait ce qui est bien la
moindre des choses tout de suite on a
retiré la police parce qu'on a
l'habitude que la classe ouvrière se
défende et le calme est revenu ça n'a
pas empêché la grève d'être puissante et
de porter une immense espérance mais il
en était de même sur le plan des
manifestations étudiantes souvenez-vous
de ce que disait la presse après la
manifestation du stade charletti
justement
extraordinaire reconnaissance de
l'efficacité de la solidité de la
responsabilité du service d'ordre
étudiant et tout le monde criéit sa
stupeur devant ce calme magnifique la
police pour une fois n'avait pas fait de
provocation alors depuis on a beaucoup
menti là-dessus mais tout le monde sait
bien que dans la pareil d'information on
a menti pas mal pourquoi ne pas admettre
qu'une fois de plus on a menti
énormément si bien que le problème c'est
pas
ça le problème il est de
savoir que voulaient les grvistes
pendant ce mois de mai des millions de
Françaises et de Français ont connu une
grande espérance ils ont pensé qu'enfin
quelque chose de précis allait pouvoir
changer dans leur vie quotidienne au
travail dans leur rapport avec le patron
et c'est cette espérance là à laquelle
maintenant il faut donner une vraie
traduction politique il faut en faire le
moyen de changer la structure de
l'entreprise comme la structure de
l'État et ça c'est tout à fait possible
à qui voulez-vous que ça fasse peur
d'autres qu'à ceux qui ont intérêt et
puis enfin il est pas venu par hasard ce
mouvement de Mai il répond à de
véritables difficultés qui traversaient
le pays à de vraies préoccupations si
l'on y répond pas du tout mais on va
voir revenir tous ces problèmes quelle
assurance de transformation dans le
calme pouvons nous donner mieux que de
commencer tout de suite les
transformations dont le pays a besoin ce
qui est le seul moyen justement qu'elle
se fasse à temps et dans le calme nous
en arrivons maintenant justement à
parler de ces transformations
c'est-à-dire de votre programme ou des
méthodes que vous envisagez pour ce
socialisme parce que si le socialisme
est certainement un état d'esprit une
philosophie générale des rapports
économiques sociaux politiques à
l'intérieur d'une société donnée ça doit
doit se traduire néanmoins concrètement
dans la vie courante alors le socialisme
tel que vous en parlez comment
concrètement dans la vie de tous les
jours il s'explique il se traduit c'est
d'abord là qu'il s'explique et qu'il se
traduit c'est pas une philosophie le
socialisme c'est d'abord le fait de se
sentir solidaire de ceux qui n'ont pas
eu toutes les chances dans la société ça
commence comme ça et puis après ça se
traduit
par une pratique et des objectifs pour
tous les jours
effectivement nous évoquions tout à
l'heure un problème celui du logement
ben regardons avec précision qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire nous constatons quoi
nous constatons d'abord que le prix du
terrain est soumis à une spéculation
invraisemblable il faut sur ce point
faire cesser cette spéculation
du point de vue de la loi c'est pas très
difficile à inventer il faut
municipaliser les sols donner à nos
communes la possibilité de contrôler
progressivement s'approprier le sol dont
elles ont besoin pour faire une grande
politique de construction pas difficile
à inventer mais très difficile à faire
parce qu'il y a des tas de gens qui
n'ont pas intérêt à ce que ça se fasse
et c'est déjà une bataille et puis il y
en a une
deuxième des sociétés privées maintenant
construisent beaucoup en France elles le
font en recherchant le maximum du du
profit possible c'est-à-dire en
construisant trop cher des logements
pour les Français les plus riches et pas
assez de logement pour ceux qui ont le
pouvoir d'achat moyen de l'ensemble des
salariés de ce pays qui ne trouvve pas à
se loger il faut changer cela et par
conséquent changer la nature même de
l'activité du bâtiment il faut créer un
service national de l'habitat qui est à
sa disposition de très grandes
entreprises soit que des entreprises
privées exécute les normes du plan soit
qu'on nationalise certaines d'entre
elles soit aussi qu'on en crée de
nouvelles des entrepr ise publique
pilote qui font de l'expérimentation
mais qui construiront à pas cher et
beaucoup là encore la définition elle
est toute simple mais il faut imposer ça
au détenteur du profit privé qui
aujourd'hui maîtrise complètement ce
secteur d'activité de notre pays faut il
faut lui imposer ou le supprimer il faut
lui imposer et petit à petit le
supprimer on verra comment ça se passe
on ne nationalisera pas tout d'un seul
coup ça n'a aucun sens la
nationalisation c'est difficile à faire
c'est souvent nécessaire mais difficile
à faire la clé c'est de définir des
objectifs précis de s'en donner les
moyens et en effet quelques
nationalisation en sont les moyens et
puis après on impose ces objectifs et on
s'explique avec cell des entreprises qui
ne suivent pas les objectifs du plan et
dans l'entreprise le socialisme au
niveau de l'entreprise ça serait quoi
pour les ouvriers pour les cadres pour
les
techniciens plutôt que de dire ça serait
quoi faut dire comment ça commence
dans l'entreprise le problème pour
chaque travailleur qu'il soit ouvrier ou
cadre ou mensuel ou technicien en effet
c'est qu'il dépend de conditions de
travail qui n'a jamais discuté pour
lesquelles il ne pèse en rien sur le
sort qui lui est fait
l'embauche le salaire la promotion la
formation et puis surtout le
licenciement tout ça dépend des gens que
dans la plupart des grandes entreprises
d'ailleurs on n jamais vu on ne connaît
pas ils sont même pas là vous vous
souvenez de cette grève étonnante qui
avait pour premier objectif que le
patron veut bien descendre de Paris
jusque dans l'usine on ne l'avait jamais
vu et c'était un objectif de grève c'est
tout de même
extraordinaire obtenir dès le niveau de
l'atelier que les travailleurs discutent
les cadences et délibèrent et puissent
contrôler et même refuser les cadences
et l'organisation du travail qu'au
niveau de l'usine la paye et l'embauche
et la la formation professionnelle dans
l'entreprise soit soumise au contrôle
des travailleurs c'est une exigence pour
tout de suite là aussi il y a quantité
d'exemples à Amien il n'y a pas très
longtemps les ouvrières d'une entreprise
textile ont imposé leur contrôle sur le
livre de paye
pourquoi parce que bien sûr le patron
déclarait des salaires minimas très bas
puis tout le monde était payé un peu
au-dessus mais à son seul gré et ceux
qui étaaient le plus augmenté celle qui
était le plus augmenté plutôt c'était
bien sûr celle qui ne se syndiquait pas
trop qui était bien sage et qui ne
discutait pas les décisions résultat un
très grand arbitraire et un très grand
scandale une injustice ouverte
maintenant que l'ensemble des
travailleurs et des travailleuses de
cette entreprise regarde discute les
conditions de la paye l'arbitraire n'est
plus possible la paye devient juste
c'est une limitation de notre dépendance
c'est un moyen d'affirmer la dignité des
travailleurs et de chacun d' on retrouve
ce même problème au niveau de la
formation il y a une grande entreprise
de mécanique où la formation dans
l'entreprise est aussi soumise au
contrôle des travailleurs ils l'ont
arraché et on s'est aperçu comme ça que
c'était le seul moyen par exemple pour
que des travailleurs immigrés reçoivent
les mêmes promotions professionnelles
quand ils en ont les capacités que des
travailleurs français et une nouvelle
solidarité ouvrière aîné c'est étonnant
pour les cadres vous avez le même
problème celui de pouvoir connaître et
discuter les décis on se souvient de
cette grande entreprise où les cadres
ont fait une grève sur le thème
l'entreprise est mal gérée vous nous
avez monsieur le patron appris à gérer
mieux fait subir des stages pour ça et
ça nous permet de découvrir que vous
menez l'entreprise à la catastrophe
alors il faut changer il faut que nous
puissions discuter des décisions voilà
ce que c'est le contrôle des
travailleurs voilà concrètement comment
aujourd'hui commence le problème du
socialisme oui mais alors quel sera le
rôle de l'État justement de l'État
socialiste dans cette perspective est-ce
qu'il va animer ces ces ces différents
combats qui vont se mener à l'entreprise
qui vont se mener sur le logement qui
vont se mener dans les différents
secteurs de l'économie quel sera le rôle
de
l'État d'abord la responsabilité n'est
pas diffuse elle s'exerce là où chacun
vit et produit et sur les décisions dont
il dépend et c'est parfaitement clair
quand dans un atelier les travailleurs
discutent les normes et les cadences
qu'on leur a imposé et refusent les
cadences excessives c'est pas diffus
c'est très net si le monde paysan arrive
à s'organiser suffisamment pour pouvoir
contre
l'usage qui est fait de son produit la
manière dont on le transforme et dont il
est distribué c'est pas diffus du tout
et alors au-dessus de tout ça quelle est
la fonction de
l'état l'État c'est une effroyable
machine tentaculaire énorme il faut le
décentraliser il faut que ce dont dépend
notre vie quotidienne ça soit décidé
dans la commune et dans la région l'état
il est responsable du plan c'està-dire
des grandes orientations il est
responsable aussi
de politiques étrangère des orientations
diplomatiques du pays et il est
responsable aussi de la défense
c'est-à-dire de la possibilité que nous
avons d'interdire à d'autres de nous
empêcher de faire chez nous la société
que nous voulons pas de force de frappe
pas d'attaque contre personne mais que
personne n'essae de nous imposer ses
volontés de l'extérieur et puis l'État a
une dernière responsabilité c'est que
dans cette lutte contre les intérêts
capitalistes contre le
profit il faudra bien sûr que au niveau
de l'État lui-même même la lutte soit
poursuivie c'est l'ensemble des
travailleurs c'est le leurs
organisations syndicales qui l'amèent
d'abord mais l'état aussi il a son rôle
là et c'est pour ça que votre vote
trouve aussi un sens en cette matière
mais est-ce que votre état admettra la
pluralité des partis politiques par
exemple absolument absolument euh nous
savons aujourd'hui que le socialisme ça
ne se fait pas sans la liberté l'exemple
de l'Union soviétique montre au
contraire que un état répressif une
planification bureaucratique ça craque
ça ne marche pas dans un pays comme le
nôtre qui est éduqué où les travailleurs
sont compétents et organisé le respect
plein et entier de la liberté c'est une
condition de notre progrès commun notre
progrès commun il passe par la recherche
scientifique on ne fait pas de recherche
scientifique sans liberté pour tout le
monde alors du coup liberté d'expression
pour tous les courants liberté pour tous
les partis il y a trop de partis c'est
vrai tout le monde le regrette on ne
supprime ça pas on ne supprimera pas ça
par voie d'autorité impossible chaque
courant qui a quelque chose à dire a le
droit de le dire et c'est au français de
choisir monsieur Rocard il faut aussi
aborder les problèmes de politique
étrangère nous avons longuement parler
des problèmes de politique intérieure
c'est très important ça préoccupe les
Français c'est vrai mais il y a aussi
dans l'hypothèse où nous nous plaçons
d'une candidature socialiste et d'un
État socialiste il y aura des problèmes
à se poser notamment en matière
d'alliance Atlantique en matière
d'Europe enfin il faudra prendre
position sur l'ensemble des problèmes de
la politique étrangère alors queles sont
les grandes orientations et bien c'est
même une condition on ne pourra
commencer à faire en France une
transformation socialiste que si nous en
avons conquis la liberté
et le principal problème qui se trouve
posé aujourd'hui c'est celui de la
domination que lentement les États-Unis
d'Amérique essayent d'imposer au monde
entier regardez l'admirable peuple du
Vietnam qui presque depuis 20 ans et en
tout cas depuis 5 ou 6 mène dans la
pauvreté une extraordinaire lutte qui
est en train de devenir victorieuse pour
arracher le droit de faire chez lui la
société qu'il a envie de faire sans
dépendre de
personne cet exemple est précis il fait
apparaître ce que c'est aujourd'hui que
l'impérialisme américain chez nous il
prend un autre visage lentement les
grandes entreprises américaines les
milieux financiers américains rachètent
nos entreprises se donneent le moyen de
contrôler notre économie à cela il faut
mettre un terme nous ne voulons pas de
cette sociétél fondé uniquement sur
l'argent fondé uniquement
sur le confort les valeurs matérielles
nous voulons faire une société juste et
digne et nous croyons que le socialisme
en est la seule possibilité alors
concrètement vis-à-vis de l'Alliance
atlantique ça veut dire qu'on en sort ça
veut dire qu'on se dégage de tout ce que
fait l'impérialisme américain dans le
monde et qu'on se prépare à se rendre
libre par rapport à ces décisions en
1969 la France a la possibilité d'en
sortir il faut que chaque candidat à
cette élection présidentielle dise
clairement ses intentions à cet égard
nous pensonsnous que la France doit en
sortir et sur l'Europe
ah
l'Europe l'Europe en ce moment c'est le
capitalisme qui a tenté de la faire et
le résultat c'est qu'elle se défait
elle-même parce qu'elle est
capitaliste regardons ce que cela nous a
apporté l'Europe pour les paysan c'est
la baisse des prix c'est une politique
agricole impossible et qui est vouée à
l'échec pour les travailleurs c'est les
politiques de chômage importé
d'Allemagne c'est chacun se méfiant de
l'autre et freinant chez lui pour qu'il
n'y ait plus de catastrophe alors pour
s'y prendre autrement imaginons
d'abord le l'effet formidable cor pour
l'ensemble des travailleurs de l'Europe
le fait qu'en France la transformation
socialiste commence et qu'un pouvoir
socialiste répondant au soucis aux
intérêts des travailleurs commence à les
garantir mieux alors là où les choses
sont difficiles prenons l'exemple de des
charbonnag par exemple ou celui des
transports ferroviaires ou celui de nos
mines de fer si un gouvernement
socialiste trouve vraiment les solutions
c'est faire à temps les conversions
prévoir les entreprises nouvelles et
qu'ailleurs les problèmes n'ont pas de
solution la lutte de l'ensemble des
travailleurs de l'Europe ira vers les
mêmes objectifs chaque fois que quelque
chose peut être fait qui limite le
profit capitaliste nous en serons
d'accord qui donne le droit de regard à
la collectivité sur ses affaires nous en
serons d'accord chaque fois qu'une idée
concernant l'Europe risque de renforcer
le capitalisme nous la combattrons nous
la refuserons Michel roard une dernière
question lorsque lesé lecteurs se
présente devant l' dans l'isoloir il a
besoin de voter utile et de voter
efficace alors à quoi ça sert de voter
Michel Rocard ça sert à deux choses la
première c'est que c'est pas un vote de
droite c'est un vote de gauche et c'est
très important parce que si d'aventure
des Françaises des Français des
travailleurs se laissaient convaincre de
voter poè au premier tour nous aurions
ce résultat que la droite se croirait
tout permis qu'elle aurait une liberté
totale qu'il n'y aurait plus de limite à
ses ambitions et au caractère
réactionnaire de sa politique et puis
ensuite la gauche est en mauvais état
nous le savons il n'y a pas de Tarche
plus urgente que de la reconstruire et
on ne peut pas la reconstruire autrement
qu'autour d'un projet socialiste c'est
ça le sens de ma candidature et c'est
pour cela qu'il est important qu'un très
grand nombre de voix viennent renforcer
le courant socialiste et par là
entreprendre cette reconversion de la
gauche qui est notre tâche la plus
urgente